okay vince i'm going to come to you what
do you think of this idea of
counseling debt for developing countries
or do you have other radical solutions
you'd prefer well you could i mean
canceling debt is a fairly standard
procedure for very poor countries um and
it's not a problem
i think you have to distinguish between
different kinds of developing countries
in radically different you've got china
and india which are continental
economies
um they have internal debt problems i
don't know whether you've read in the
paper the last few days they've even
been
riots in chinese cities the last few
days because you know big property
companies sort of loaded with debt about
to go bankrupt it's going to affect the
rest of the banking system so you know
but it's an internal problem for china
nothing to do with us
similarly in india you get state banks
that lend money to farmers
politicians go around and have what they
call debt mellers where they write off
all the debts of the farmers and that
creates bad debt for the banks and so
there are internal issues affected with
that that those countries have to worry
about it's not an international problem
and then you have the poorest countries
in africa
very low income countries which where
most of their debt is as a result of um
aid you know they borrowed money from
the world bank
or from the british deferred or
increasingly from the chinese banks
and they accrue a certain debt with it
but you know these are very very poor
countries
um particularly at times of distress
when will commodity prices are very low
for example
you know coffee is fetching half or a
third of the trend price you know they
default or they have to default they
simply can't pay it it's not they won't
pay it they can't pay it
and there is a procedure um
partly through the so-called paris club
um and partly through aid agencies
collaborating where but we write off
some of the debt and that's a good thing
to do and sensible
the problem at the moment is that
western countries are reluctant to write
off the debt because
they worry that the money will then go
to service the chinese debts and the
chinese are reluctant to give debt
relief because they think the money will
be used to pay our institutions so
there's a bit of a standoff but
you know in terms of concept there isn't
a big problem the real issue which is
going to hit us very hard in the next
year or two is in the big emerging
economies brazil is probably the first
in line
turkey
certainly argentina
you know these are semi-developed
countries which borrowed heavily when
the economy seemed to be doing well in a
boom time commodity prices were high
people had a lot of confidence in them
and they borrowed from
u.s banks british banks
and now they face a situation where
their income is stagnating interest
rates are going up
and you know you get to a point where
either their governments get into high
levels of inflation which is not
beginning to happen in argentina they're
back up to 30 40 percent
um or they simply default i mean
argentina has defaulted
well four times since the war
yeah um you know some countries like
guatemala have been defaulting every few
years since 1800
um it's actually become a bad habit in
some of those countries and you're
mostly there dealing with
commercial debt and there's a bargaining
process
with which the imf may or may not get
involved and there is no good argument
for just writing off the debt and it's
not a humanitarian issue it's a question
of the
the balance of um you know whether you
whether one wants to be penal
or not and to establish their credit
awareness but it's not a moral issue
whereas i think if you're dealing with
uganda or you know ghana maybe it is a
moralist
is there a solution to the emerging
markets debt
issue well not for the poorest countries
but as you say the kind of the real-ish
the real
the real crux of the issue well
i guess brazil will probably try to keep
its debt service they value their credit
worthiness the argentines are just you
know
um
they just default over and over again
uh and there's nothing that you can do
about it apart from changing their
politics but we can't do that no no
steven same question to you
um
you know
economists like to talk about moral
hazard that aside from the poorest
countries of the world where there's an
argument to cancelling their debt a lot
of that in emerging markets um
you know
should that
if you if you were to cancel their debt
does that create a moral hazard issue
where whatever led them to accumulate
the debt it just perpetuates that
behavior so it partly depends on why
they've got the debt in the first place
and of course we know from the cold war
that many uh poorer states in
sub-saharan africa were in debt partly
because there was a battle uh of
kindness in one sense between the
soviets and the americans to to offer
them lots of money and when things went
badly wrong the cold war itself came to
an end uh there was no interest actually
continuously perpetuating those loans
once the cold war was over so they ended
up in terrible terrible trouble
but let's come back to argentina uh
obviously vince is particularly keen in
argentina um and i think there's lots of
reasons for being a little bit skeptical
about argentina you go back to around
about 1890 argentina is one of the
richest economies in the world and
actually if you were to look at
argentina's progress over the previous
20 years and you're betting on how
successful it would be compared with say
germany at that time you might well have
concluded that argentina today would be
the richer country uh rather than
germany are you being wrong uh but it
wouldn't seem like a particularly stupid
bet back in 1890 and vince is right much
of argentina's difficulty is a sort of
domestic political economy difficulty it
has a structural problem which is that
uh for many years it's had an unusually
low level of savings domestically it's
just a structural demographic issue
which is different from other countries
and because it has that low level of
domestic savings it is very very
dependent and has always been dependent
on money coming in from abroad if you
like the kindness of strangers to make
sure that it can actually invest for the
future grow rapidly and expand
unfortunately argentina's domestic
politics and political economy have not
been consistent with looking after the
interests of those foreign creditors and
as you come back to
i think argentina has more financial
crises than any other country over the
last 100 years
and if you are a perpetual
crisis country
whereby you seem to play fast and loose
with the creditors money
the chances are that your initial
prospect of success will fall away very
quickly
so you might say well forgive argentina
it's difficulties currently but if you
were to do that it would in one sense
perpetuate a sense that argentina can
get away with the kinds of behaviors
demonstrated over the course of the last
100 years
so i think what is slightly worrying
about this and where i i think with
grace's comments about the global north
and global south i think the global
south is is there's much more
granularity than i think you've
described there's so many different
kinds of countries out there with
different sets of problems uh to lump
them all together i think is probably a
mistake in my view i i would suggest
that there are plenty of countries out
there that yes have difficulties i think
particularly parts of sub-saharan africa
obviously have difficulties as vince
says yeah they default
but at the same time there are others
who frankly
um i think have brought some of their
problems upon themselves and haven't
learnt the lessons from the past to make
themselves attractive countries to be
invested in for the future can i quickly
very quickly respond so i think there's
a question here about why debt is being
accumulated and re-accumulated by some
of the the poorest countries in the
world and uh it's easy to just say well
they're just irresponsible governments
and that's why you know you had debt
cancellation and then uh things went
badly again of course the part of the
reason that we had debt cancellation in
the first place particularly for many of
the poorest countries in the world was
that those countries had what we called
odious debt so debts that were left over
from colonialism that weren't taken out
by democratic governments and were
therefore cancelled because you know
basically people were paying the price
for governments that they had no
accountability to you see that a lot uh
continuously today um with autocratic
governments basically taking on lots of
debt and then the poorest people in
those societies being forced to pay the
costs of that we saw that recently with
a scandal of british banks facilitating
lending to um and it was mozambique or
angola uh and that money basically
disappearing into the pockets of corrupt
officials and then you know those
countries defaulting in it being again
the poorest people in the world who are
being forced to pay for the consequences
of that the reason that a lot of these
countries continuously accumulate more
debt when that debt has been cancelled
is because they are often particularly
the poorest countries less over the
semi-peripheral countries in a position
of um you know dependence and
exploitation within the global economy
the reason that china has been able to
get out of that position is because it's
been able to kind of get around a lot of
laws around intellectual property which
have allowed it to develop high value
high value manufacturing by forcing
western multinationals to get into
partnerships with domestic companies
that facilitated its own development a
lot of other countries are and will
remain dependent upon commodities
exports and commodities prices obviously
go up and down they go up and down daily
they go up and down in a big super cycle
and when you see a big collapse in
commodities prices then those countries
can no longer pay their debts so really
the only way to get those countries out
of this trap of accumulating debt is
allowing them to develop allowing them
to industrialize allowing them to
develop a sustainable path towards
growth and that requires not just aid
not just transfers but actually the
sharing of intellectual property
rewriting tax treaties rewriting
investment treaties
so i think we're agreed for the poorest
countries to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai
dot tv for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you